tra i try buy e stavolta non picanto
hannah montana l'intero il video è vi è
andata pure bene cioè nel senso ha fatto
cose molto peggiori tipo quella travolta
mixer a leggere ed harris the beast e
non è stato proprio il massimo però come
l'ultimo episodio di 100 force volevo
chiudere insomma in bellezza
risparmiandovi un po di timpani bella
tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
video stavo per sbattere la faccia sulla
scrivania mentre facevo così però non
fatevi dare niente volevo dirvi che
siamo finalmente finale porca vacca e
ora e non a parte gli scherzi è durato
tanto cento flash un senso questo
parlando come se tutto finisse magari
non riesco a fare gli enigmi quindi devo
fare 26 episodi però oggi dovrebbe
essere l'ultima parte di 100 forze
perché mancano gli ultimi 15 livelli
dell'ultima torre dell'ultimo giochiamo
allora abbiamo fatto la torre principale
che sono i primi 100 piani poi la torre
a knicks che sono non mi ricordo quanti
ma sono tanti e la season tower e poi
c'è molto altro in arrivo non è vero e
così da vent'anni e ringraziando anche
dio abbiamo fatto della season tower
tutto tranne valentine specials quindi
chiudiamo con l'ultima torre di 100
prossimi ultimi quindici piani immagino
quindi sì tanto al tema san valentino
quindi tutti gli innamorati si limonino
adesso che dopo non c'è spazio il primo
piano di tutto fare questi video proprio
a tema tipo quando erano tale avrei
dovuto fare quelli natale a san
valentino avrei dovuto far questo invece
no proviamoci tutto questo è un cuore
perché io sono un maschio ma non penso
solo alle cose brutte ma penso anche
all'amore
quindi questo livello lo so fare le cose
con chi state parlando rai allora 14
febbraio è stato bellissima st musica
vorrebbe un sacco voglia di limonare il
telefono ma non lo farò mon amour toc
toc l'amore bussa una volta sola l'altra
volta se la chiava qualcun altra cosa
devo fare qua a devo cambiare posso
cambiare il calendario c'è una foglia
lapillo
c'è una foglia che inserisco lì non ho
capito niente di quello che ho fatto ma
va bene così
mia nonna aveva un muro uguale giuro mia
nonna aveva il muro era questo la
franzoni anno devo dodo attivo più
inclinare il tele st tecnologia non sono
pronto
e vabbè questi cuori che passano come si
fa
ci deve essere un piano inclinato del
telefono in particolare tipo questa
vacca live non mi mandate i messaggi
aiuto mi ha mandato i messaggi non mi
vedo altri messaggi sconcentrato macello
dai voglio trovare l'anima gemella
quanto difficile vivere una relazione a
questo antico questa questo sono io in
bilico con la mia relazione sentimentale
è la situazione sentimentale sorry
l'amore è difficile da mantenere lo
sappiamo tutti però dove ma non posso
dirlo fermo core di tono l'amore non si
può tenere fermo col dito era una cosa
molto filosofica qui dove l'altro cuore
di mortacci sua la roma sembra scemo
piace né non due non sono scemo
eccoli i malati scemi era un ora che
facciamo così che schiacciavo ma non fa
dal resto gioco più andiamo avanti che
meglio meglio singoli giuro li mortacci
vostri cosa devo fare qua vattene
ragione non sto capendo losito cliccare
devo accenderle tutte immagini
[Musica]
ok allora ragazzi allora l'importante è
vincere poi chissenefrega
poi chi se ne frega di come funzionano
le cose va bene così poteva aprire la
porta sarà mica un cuore questo il cuore
più bello che vedrà in tutta la tua vita
visto era veramente quali luci festa era
talmente stupido che non pensavo fosse
quello ok alla volta le cose più stupide
sono le piove a parigi non è ovvio se
metti un paio di altri cuori che vanno
su e giù chi giro ti ammazzo questo e
cupido non lo sparare ai cori questi
scendono a caso zio come funziona a devo
colpire curva e non è difficile o no a
devo colpirli insieme a figo collateral
e vero cupito deve fare un sacco di
collateral per chi non sapesse cosa sono
in collateral
non ha giocato a call of duty per un
sacco di tempo cioè quando andava di
moda fari colla tra timor chiavi un
sacco di film siamo avanti anche loro
secondo me divorziano un sacco ebbene a
quest'ultima torre di 100 per os x che
mi mettevo tranquillità 007 james bond a
devi illuminato da qualcuno che mi
spiega scusate ma secondo me devo fare
il giorno di san valentino
jones valentino è il 14 2 però quale al
contrario perché siamo in america quindi
2 14
ecco così però opposto va bene allora
queste due se puntano fanno uno quindi
24 ore ok quindi devo spostare questi
due
effetto perfetto tutto qui ho dovuto
usare il cervello questa volta l'ho
usato sul serio una delle poche volte
però funziona quando girare tutti i
cuori ma mai a quanto sta diventando
molto difficile sto gioco no perché io
nelle cose logiche che preferisco allora
le cose matematica non capisco una mazza
se si tratta d'amore se si tratta di
patata diventa un gene quindi ecco un
altro io lancio un messaggio adesso se
qualcuno o qualcuna ha bisogno di
consigli d'amore per dal sottoscritto mi
scrivete un messaggio bozza p e io vi do
la mia consulenza ce lo fanno tipo
quelli su televideo però io lo faccio
questi tubi se avete bisogno di consigli
d'amore sapere se il vostro la vostra
anima gemella ricambia wanda ciao e 48 2
48 e fa vj vedo dice in regalo una roba
del genere nella tana cagata però sempre
si è dato dirlo almeno una volta direbbe
capire come funzionano
ora questo nuove quei tre questo momenti
3 a tutti i muovono quelli di fianco dai
basta ti prego è veramente estenuante
sta roba estenuante so parlare italiano
grazie a dio che rimorchio e imposte lo
giuro e infattibile cm o hai un cuore di
ferro o impossibile però è veramente un
casino rega c'è vi giuro sta roba
veramente un casino ma perché non ti
stanno mai diritti tutti i venti scemo
ma come eros forti ma erano sorti ma non
avevo mettere tutti i diritti allora con
io ho finalmente che devo seguire un
ordine o che bello allora in giro un
genio che alcune cose riesco a capirlo
subito sono sicuro che segue umbrella
ombrello inizia con la u in inglese
quindi up usa ap disco di quindi da un
giu
rosa destra a volte capisco le cose mi
devo vantare solo un livello capisco su
15 quindi fatemi vantare
non ho mai capito se devo scambiare di
posizione o cosa devo fare perché così a
ok di raisi dove solo di stanziarli not
dead
ma dove munire un cuore spezzato e ci ho
provato un sacco di volte nella vita non
sono mai riuscito ha dovuto ha dovuto
carico si verdi ma cos'è era ma che
cagate ma cos'era
ma che roba ma cos'è va perché perché io
mi impegno a cagare
pensavo fossero baracca nella caduta
non ci sono più alemi in vite allen in
allin in un the valentine parco demonio
si no sbagliato
era l'ultima vale no era facile questo
nodo trovarne uno dove sono tutti vicini
capiti capisco
va però edifici ceva accumulo tipo
ma proprio devo fare uno in cui sono
vicini vale
[Musica]
amici miei
vi voglio bene tantissima via moviamo ci
diamo allora quando mi sfidare gli
ingranaggi dell'amore se dio vuole ad
infilare in alto ok la più grossa il più
piccolo
quindi io io pensavo dovessero
combaciare i dentini me c'erano solo da
mettere in ordine ma vai a cagare tetto
sorella mancano il mancano due solo due
solo only ci bastava questo è un uomo
che ci prova la tipa non ci sta però le
andai in cambio dei cubi quindi è chiaro
che la risposta è la donna di picche
perché la donna da piquet ha sì quindi
semplicemente lavorativo il primo è il
re che dalla rosa quindi io giochi joker
si è fatto di rose e gli dal cuore poi
ci sono i sei curve e poi c'è la donna
easy peasy game ragazzi l'ultimo piano
di 100 floors l'ultimo st cagate qua è
l'ultimo piano di 100 floris vediamo se
riesco a fare qualcosa di decente a devo
cambiare l'ordine dei cosi va bene
notare che poi c'è tutti attacchi al
pensano cosa devo fare
a devo sbloccare la porta ok is it easy
una sega perché in realtà cioè casi nato
di quanto pensi però poi dall'altro deve
cadere anche nel cestino ma sto male e
no macello il cestino ma io non posso
spostare il cestino
alla fine tutto il falso bordello dei
cade pure nel cestino
vabbè pisino
attenzione attenzione o no vabbè sto
male e che siamo anche noi che stava
gestirà somma non dovevo muoverlo il
cestino
sto male penso avevano fatto tutto
giusto propri doveri farlo per il
cestino non si spostava ok molto altro
in arrivo non è vero sto gioco è finito
di essere sviluppato nel 2012 quindi
ragazzo oggi sono soddisfattissimo
perché va bene l'ultimo l'ho fatto a
caso non fa quelli ve li ho fatti a caso
ma un sacco os portato io spero che vi
sia piaciuta la serie su 100 floors
questa è la conclusione totale però che
video vi sia piaciuto un bacino a tutti
con san valentino anche se siamo ottobre
ma stia ragazzi spero che sia piaciuto
seguito è più certo momento non mi piace
anche all'istituto tale descrizione se
non siete riusciti iscrivetevi riceviamo
al prossimo san valentino
se non siamo frenati da ragazzi
[Musica]